gentlemen I just want to start with a
sincere congratulations on this uh you
guys made a fantastic movie thank you um
so uh individual question to start
things off for each of you I'm going to
start with you I'm a big fan of your
work I'm curious of the films you've
made which film changed the most in the
editing room in ways you didn't expect
going in that's such an interesting
question that's a really interesting
question because there are films I've
made that have very complex torial
structures like my Bob Dylan biop Pig
I'm not there for instance or velvet
Gold Mine both of those are music driven
popular artist driven stories but I
would say in some ways
Carol I think underwent some
transformative decision-making in the
editing room it was just too big and
long a film and it sprawled in some
different directions and it was all we
were happy with all the components but
you have to make tough choices sometimes
and and eliminate things you know and
and and sort of sear into what the real
core of the story is and that happened
in the in the process of cutting uh
Carol individual question for you uh you
are so good in this role it's such a
it's such a a great role so I guess the
big question is how much did you pay
Todd to be in it so I've been stalking
Todd for about 10 years now Charles do
we have to get into no no no no yeah no
no no
um a lot
of a lot of money being serious though
this is a great role for you so how much
did you really want this one you
know when when I read sami's script I
immediately F felt this connection to
Joe who this man was his feelings though
our experiences are different I found a
lot of parallels in my own life and to
have this opportunity it was a six- week
process of
auditioning and each day it wasn't like
I got to book this job it was more like
just discovering this uh the the way I
wanted to work and that I had this
opportunity to work like this and just
diving into just who this man was and
what he represented and just this
responsibility that he had at such a
young age that he carried to the age of
36 and just this repressed
um um human who kind of starts asking
himself the question that he's never
really had the chance to ask as we see
in the movie one of the things that I
really dug about this film one of the
many things is that I I watch a lot of
movies and often I can predict what the
next scene is going to be and where it's
all going this script has none of that I
really had no idea where it was
ultimately going to go can you talk
about that aspect of the script that it
a keeps you guessing at all times and B
it never judges anyone in the film
that's such an interesting question I
felt the same way when I read it there's
a treacherousness about how it it walks
you from around your expectations I
think and you begin to be at odds with
your own presumptions about one
character or another neither of the
central female characters are ever
redeemed in the film and you keep
shifting your sense of reliability or
trust in one versus the other but what's
so lovely about the way it's structured
is that it's the third act that opens up
this space for Charles's character Joe
to really find the focus of the film but
it happens with such a different kind of
language and it's very delicate and it's
very tender and the rest of the film
hasn't really been that way and so that
third Act is really something that the
film earns is there anything you'd like
to add everything Todd said Todd said
then I'll just say this for both of you
you're looking at the schedule you see
what you got to do you have a limited
time frame what's the day that you had
circled as to I cannot wait to film this
or holy F how are we going to film this
for me it was when I found out when tdd
called me and I found out I booked the
roll of Joe I was like I can't wait I
even went to Todd and I hung out I went
I went to Savannah a bit earlier to see
him I saw you in Portland OR La before
that too I I I don't know I just Dove
right in
and yeah you
know the the those 20 three days just
lifechanging and just the way Todd the
way he the the the the director he is
the human he is and just everybody just
was were at the top of their game and it
was just so collaborative and so
intimate and so magical the whole
process I would I would I would Pro
there so there's so many scenes I was
looking forward to actually getting into
once we saw how the language was being
sort of played out the the the the
camera that holds and lets actors play
Within the frame and the mirror scenes
where the actors are playing directly to
the lens of the camera but it is I would
have to say Elizabeth's monologue that
happens toward the end of the film which
is one of the simplest scenes to shoot
but one of the most important scenes
dramatically in the film and but the
whole idea of the static camera around
the mirror originated from that think
when I first read that scene and how I
shoot it but that scene came on the
second to the last day of our shoot so
we built up to the
whole scenes in the in the in and that
was the second to the last day and it
was just a
remarkable inexplicable thing to watch
that that actor Natalie Portman create
yeah when I was watching it I was
wondering how because that's a
performance and you need to be
emotionally ready to deliver that so I'm
I'm sure she knew that was coming on
that day yeah I mean every day was
loaded because it was such a tight
schedule every day was like okay here we
go to get through it you know it was it
was a challenge but it just felt like we
were all in it together everybody had a
role to play everybody was essential to
the process of it succeeding so
everybody felt needed and I think that
shared the sense of all that we were all
part of it it was a true collaborative
experience on that note I have to stop
I'm just going to say congratulations
and good luck with the rest of your
speed
dating